the whitney houston version of of that
song i think you're talking the book
about when you heard
her version they had asked me about the
song
of months before because they were
looking for a song for that
bodyguard movie because the one they had
planned to use
someone else covered so they were
looking for a song and i guess
they thought well dolly's song if i will
always love you might be a good one
so they asked me about it i sent it and
i forgot about it and i was driving home
in my car from my office going through
brentwood a little town mount where i
live
and uh in nashville and i just heard
this voice come on the radio
like if i should stay it was like it's
kind of ring a bell but it didn't hit
because she was
kind of talking it and then all of a
sudden it went into the
outer laws love you part and i had to
pull off the side of the road
seriously to listen to it but it was one
of the most
overwhelming feelings i've ever had to
hear that
done so well so beautiful so big
had no idea i'd written a song that
could be that important
and i didn't i think she just took it
and made it so much
more than what it would have ever been
but it was such a thrill
and a joy as a songwriter i don't think
i'll ever have a greater thrill
[Music]
ever
you